bei mir im studio ist jetzt stark auch
alexander herrmann fast jeder kennt ihn
aus dem fernsehen
herrmann heute erscheint ihre
autobiografie mit dem titel und eine
prise wahnsinn
dort schreiben sie auch über zwei
einschneidende erlebnisse in ihrem leben
1981 sterben ihre eltern beim autounfall
sie waren gerade mal neun jahre alt und
jetzt vor zehn jahren die diagnose
hautkrebs diese beiden ereignisse
erlebnisse wie haben sie sie verändert
grundsätzlich ist genau das die prise
wahnsinn im leben auf die man gern
verzichtet aber die ein natürlich auch
prägt die aus einem negativ moment
heraus einem aber auch die chance gibt
zu wachsen
und ich habe gemerkt vor allem mit in
den letzten zehn 15 jahren dass es
wichtig ist dass ich mich im grunde
gerade betrieblich nicht ganz so wichtig
nehmen sondern dass da mein team und
meine mitarbeiter an meiner seite
eigentlich die große bank sind die geben
mir auch die sicherheit all das um was
es heute eben gastronomisch als
unternehmer geht zustimmen
wie geht es ihnen jetzt heute vor zehn
jahren muss seine schockdiagnose gewesen
sein sie waren trotzdem die ganze zeit
vor der kamera man hat ihn da die
angemerkt wenn man das so sagen dafür
gibt ihn heute also wer das war damals
ja so dass ich zunächst nur eine
bestrahlung brauchte also das wurde
operativ entfernt aus dem arm nur
bestrahlung keine kino das ist schon mal
sehr sehr wichtig und für mich war
damals eine es war schon eine form von
angst ich wollte nicht dass das
öffentlich wird war in dem moment wenn
man weiß da schau her der hat gerade
eine behandlung dabei sind zwei dinge
der zuschauer
ich meine da möchte sich entspannen
möchte nicht unbewusst plötzlich sehen
da schon mal her
im kern geht es gar nicht so gut und
gleichzeitig ist natürlich auch die
fürsorgepflicht der der
senderverantwortlichen die die natürlich
gerne aus seiner sendung dann
herausnehmen und hier die chance geben
zu pausieren und das wollte ich ja
eigentlich nicht und gleichzeitig immer
glück im unglück das war damals so im
juni juli und ja juli august sind wenig
aufzeichnungen gewesen und deswegen
konnte ich meinen letzten damals
küchenschlacht block beim zdf den konnte
ich damals im grünen noch durchziehen
ohne dass es einer gemerkt hat und mich
dann ein bisschen erholen heutzutage na
ja das ist natürlich verarbeitet und
es geht mir natürlich gut punkt sehr gut
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren